hello everyone if you compare the immune
system of our body to the defense system
of our country then the t-cells of our
immune system is very much comparable to
the armed military force
they are like soldiers right there like
trained soldiers and in this video I'll
be talking about how a cells develop
inside the thymus but first things first
before even thinking about what type of
training do they get in - we should
first talk about how they are born and
their birthplace
so the birthplace of t-cell is the bone
marrow especially the big bones let's
say the femur bone so inside the bone
there would be specific regions there
would be vascular and industrial niche
and in these specific niche the teeth
the the t-cell or the B cell is born
from the progenitor from the
hematopoietic pluripotent stem cell now
this hematopoietic pluripotent stem cell
give rise to lymphoid progenitor or
myeloid progenitor and this neutral
progenitor is the important one because
this give rise to the adaptive immune
system components whereas the mylar
potential give rise to innate lymphoid
progenitor in sequential step give rise
to t-cell precursor T cell precursors
are also progenitor by virtue and also B
cell precursor now P cell remains in the
bone marrow and their development take
place in the bone marrow whereas the
t-cell precursor will leave the bone
marrow in order for them to go to a
school which is thymus so they entered
the bloodstream
and reach the thymus thymus is simply
the training school of T cell if we cut
a cross-section of the thymus we get a
view like that
now thymus is anatomically subdivided
into several region and we'll talk about
that its significance
so inside the thymus there are timer
sites which are immature t-cells there
are also timing epithelial cells and the
whole thymus is divided into several
layers like sub capsular region which is
the peripheral most region then cortex
medulla quarterly cortical Junction and
then the medulla the T cells entered the
thymus from the high endothelial venule
now once they entered the thymus they
move towards our periphery and they
gather in the sub capsular region in the
sub capsular region these T cell
procedures can divide and amplify their
number so they really divide and amplify
their number in the sub capsular region
from sub capsular region they descend
down to the cortex and in this process
they encounter thymic epithelial cells
which gives them important training so
tymek epithelial cells could be
considered as the teachers of these T
cells at this point of time these T
cells are really mature they would
undergo several degree of training and
screening procedures throughout their
school from cortex they've moved down to
medulla and they also receive another
set of straining and at them after the
midler when their training is done
they'll reenter the high endothelial
venue and migrate around the other parts
of the body to the peripheral limb for
guns such as lymph nodes
it takes three week for this thymic
training to complete so it's a long time
for them right and next couple of
minutes we'll discuss what type of
training do they receive during these
three weeks so when the T cells the T
cell progenitors are in the sub capsular
region they are known as the double
negative T cell stage it's a phase of
their life you can just like we have our
teenage you can imagine the double
negative stage is a phase of the T cells
life
at this point of time they have the
t-cell receptor or the precursor of the
t-cell receptor but they don't have the
co-receptor cd8 or cd4 but the T cell
receptor could be either TCR alpha or
beta or other it could be also Gamma
Delta now among these a double negative
stage there are sub stages and these sub
stages are characterized by specific
marker expression for example in DN one
stage C it is pretty high cd44 is
present whereas cd25 is not present
whereas if you compare this stage to the
DN four stage C kit and cd45 and cd25
all of these markers goes down so based
on this expression of these markers you
can kind of kind of categorize them into
specific phases now we'll talk more
about these phases in a different video
but for simplicity let's think about the
double negative stage as a unified stage
now double negative stage is the time
for the vdj rearrangement of PCR genes
just like the BCR genes TCR genes also
undergoes rearrangement and that gives
the diversity of the TCR and its ability
to interact with so many different
peptides now first the beta chain of the
TCR is rearranged and eventually and
sequentially the alpha chain would be
rearranged but they don't get rearranged
at the same time once both of the chains
are rearranged the match your PCR alpha
and beta is formed but there is also a
possibility that it would form TCR gamma
and Delta but it turns out that TCR
alpha beta is the prevalent isoform over
TCR gamma and Delta the reason I will be
deciding I'll be discussing it in a
different video but now after this
double negative stage they descend down
to the cortex
they're still in double- stage when they
go to the cortex they start expressing
both the receptors now they are termed
as double positive they'd started
expressing the cd4 positive cd4 receptor
and the cd8 co-receptor and already by
this time the dubbed by the time of
double positive stage or at the end of
the double negative stage they're PCR
gene rearrangement is done and they have
a functional TCR by that time now in
this double positive cell stage they
have both the receptors now in the
cortex there they would like first
interact with the timing epithelial
cells point to be noted there's these
double positive T cell stage is a
prevalent stage present in the thymus
almost eighty percent of the cells of
the thymus are these D P double positive
T cells now they would interact with the
thymic epithelial cells the double
positive cells has to recognize the MHC
bound peptides so this is the first
degree of their training and screening
procedure so they their job is to
understand peptides that are displayed
on the MHC in later point of their life
they have to do this job so first these
timing epithelial cells teach them how
to recognize MHC s be it a class 1 MHC
or bead a class 2 MHC now two distinct
selection procedure takes place in the
cortex one we call the positive
selection in this selection the teachers
that means the thymic epithelial cell or
the thymus ensures that these T cells
who are double positive they learn how
to recognize MHC bound molecule so they
ensure the MHC restriction and there is
also a procedure of negative selection
in this procedure they learn Rickett
they learn how to recognize the MHC
molecules but the high affinity
interactions
are kind of killed so this particular
negative selection ensures that self
tolerance is maintained and there is no
autoreactive T cells generated in case
of many autoimmune diseases this
negative selection mechanism fails which
creates which turns our own defense
system against our body which is
detrimental we would learn about these
negative and positive selection slowly
and in lot more details
so first let's say this particular T
cell can recognize the MHC bound peptide
now these peptides are mostly self
peptides produced by these thymic
epithelial cells in this particular
stage their goal is to just to get
familiarized with the peptides
associated with MHC now if the if these
T cells can recognize MHC bound peptide
then they would proceed further and they
do go for the next level of screening
and imagine if the don't or they fail to
recognize these MHC bond peptides they
would die by neglect and it turns out
almost ninety percent of this population
is dead because they cannot recognize
MHC bound peptide with a decent affinity
so imagine how stringent this process is
right only ten percent remains and they
goes to the next level the next level is
a negative selection so they had to
learn how to select how to select or how
to identify MHC bond peptides but they
also make sure that you should not
engage with the high affinity
interaction so the T cells which engage
with the MHC s with a moderate level of
affinity or a low level of affinity they
goes to the next level of selection
procedure or they proceed in their
career otherwise this T cells which
recognize they make
and with very high affinity interaction
they are dead by the negative selection
procedure they undergo apoptosis and the
and this is a method of generating
tolerance and at this stage it is
decided that these cells should not
survive because if they survive they
would turn against their own body
against our own body they would create
harm in our own body and they can cause
autoimmune disorders so this time
ocation is very stringent and that makes
sure the t-cells gain specific skill
sets but they don't turn against our own
body now the job in the cortex is done
and they have quite a lot of interaction
with the
thymic epithelial cells now they defend
down from the cortex from the
subcortical medullary junctions to the
medulla where they interact with other
time akkad coracle cells and at this
stage the double positive cells either
recognize class 2 MHC or they would
recognize class 1 MHC the sub population
which would recognize class 2 MHC bound
peptides they would eventually stop
expressing cd8 and upregulate the
expression of cd4 eventually they would
become the cd4 positive helper t-cell
the population that would that would
recognize the MHC class 1 month web time
they would down-regulate expressing cd4
whereas they would up regulate
expression of the cd8
eventually they would become cd8
positive cytotoxic t-cells there is also
possibility that these t-cells that
descend down to the medulla which has
already gone negative selection
procedure they don't recognize any of
these MHC s or any of these MHC mounted
tides so they would straight card died
by neglect now there are also
possibility that they did recognize both
the classes of MHC now in that situation
they would also die by negative
selection because they cannot be
nonspecific and recognize both class one
and class two bound ma plus two MHC ion
peptides so all these different degree
of criterias and stringent policies make
the T cells really stringent and they
learn how to recognize their recognize
MHC s
and MHC bound peptides now their
training in the thymus is almost at the
verge of completion they would descend
down further the medulla reached the
high endothelial venue and now they
would migrate all around the body and
they relocate and now they are posted to
the peripheral lymphoid organ like lymph
node which are like army base camp after
these veterans which which are t-cells
which got their training now it's their
time to do the field work in order to do
the field work they have to go to the
army base camp which is the site of
action right so now they are moving to
the site of action which is the lymph
node and in the lymph node they reside
in specific barracks there is specific T
cell region present in the lymph node
there they encounter dendritic cells and
many other cells and which further
health in their differentiation and
maturation process and that I have
explained in a separate video called T
cell differentiation I would recommend
you to watch that video for a complete
experience I hope you enjoyed this video
if you liked this video give it a quick
thumbs up don't forget to Like share and
subscribe thank you and don't forget to
leave your comments below and that gives
me a lot of motivation thank you bye